depuis trois ans seuls les animaux
d'élevage comme ces truites pouvait en
consommer désormais les insectes fort
ont aussi subvenir aux besoins des
hommes l'union européenne vient en effet
de donner le feu vert à la consommation
des vers de farine en biscuit ou sous
forme de pâte
les larves du ténébrions meunier aussi
appelés vers de farine peuvent désormais
être consommée sans danger en europe
dans la somme le plus grand élevage
d'insectes du monde vient même d'ouvrir
ses portes
des insectes peu appétissant certes mais
écologique car dans ce type d'élevage
nul besoin d'eau ou de grands espaces
grillon ou sauterel onze autres demandes
de mise sur le marché pour des insectes
ont été soumises à l'union européenne
[Applaudissements]
ouah des insectes comestibles et
fondateur de jimmy's société qui vend
des insectes comestibles
bonsoir l'ancien merci d'être là alors
bastien ça y est la consommation
d'insectes net actuellement qui était
pas actuellement autorisée en europe en
france pour l'instant c'est pas autorisé
mais ça va arriver
en fait c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
que ça il ya eu 1 s'est passé ailleurs
flou juridique
il ya eu pas mal de je dirais de dalea
qui ont fait que enfin c'est autorisé
mais ça fait quand même pas mal d'années
qu'on est dans des mesures transitoires
et qu'on a le droit à manger des
insectes avant on pouvait on pouvait
mais dans certains pays dans certaines
régions et c'était assez complet quand
même assez l'unification en france ces
bons plans france on a dû se battre on
va lui on a dû aller devant les
tribunaux mais on peut depuis depuis
quelques temps déjà
alors il paraît qu'ils alors est ce que
c'est il paraît que c'est très bon
manger des insectes est ce qui est ce
qu'il est possible que plus tard on le
mange que des insectes et gilles verdez
oui parce que l'humanité va avoir besoin
des insectes et puis ça contient plein
de protéines de vitamines
c'est génial les 1 510 abl vous savez
ces villes que d'ores et déjà deux
milliards de personnes sur la planète
mange des insectes quoi c'est tout ce
qu'ils font koh lanta en amérique du sud
en asie mais comment je désinfecte ah
ouais alors un bon mois j'étais un sac
vous je mange des insectes et ben je
vois vos chroniqueurs sont très bien
informés en effet c'est quelque chose
qui va arriver mais moi j'ai connu je
mange de tout gérer ce soir bernard
enfin qui ipso ribéry non vous savez il
y en a commandé mais sa tâche et big
sean donc voilà il faut citer d'autres
marques bonjour suite à une bonne heure
kai chase et bien sûr farguaise point b
également sur wii moi j'ai une question
de pardon est ce que vous dites que ça
sera une nourriture exclusive quasiment
mais on dit que 60% des insectes ont
disparu donc je vais y avoir le même
problème qu'avec d'autres sources
alimentaires terreur être en pénurie
alors j'ai jamais dit que ce serait une
nourriture d'excusés c'est votre sujet
moi je suis pas aussi fermée que ça je
pense que c'est une alternative qui est
formidable parmi beaucoup d'autres
choses notamment la viande alors j'ai
quelqu'un sur le plateau hier qui était
extraordinaire ça bien sûr
donc voilà on prône chez d'une liste
alternative on a dans nos équipes des
gens qui sont flexitariens des gens qui
sont vegan des gens qui sont en tomo
vegan salaire tu ranges que des insectes
et de la viande
j'avais raté des choses que c'est à
l'aller nous a ramené un petit verre de
qui douche avec du café mais non mais
sans déconner c'est incroyable criquets
sauterelles criquets nomades gemini et
oui pour s'arrimer jiminy cricket issue
alors et est donc et ça donc ça se mange
c'est très bon point à manger vous mais
bien sûr passer alors sur le criquet moi
ce que je vous conseille de faire c'est
pour la première fois d'enlever elle m'a
fait de tout se mange c'est excellent ah
ouais c'est ça on peut en manger aussi
gilbert dette c'est déjà très bien je
veux bien ouais parce que la mondiale
tant que c'est gratuit vous allez voir
très bon ça va
tomates séchées % de protéines plus que
le poulet alors et à côté ça s'apprend
les téléspectateurs alors ça c'est un
petit vers de farine justement le fameux
dont vous parliez c'est maintenant paul
manger bad est restée française
agronutrition a déposé un dossier de
relève ça on peut enfin avoir cet
insecte arrivée en europe partout et ça
ça c'est quoi ça c'est bon ça ce mois en
apéritif c'est exactement cette limite
non mais alors moi je kiffe alors moi je
peux pas parce que la chan ramadan
kippour
[Rires]
jean jaurès est ce là bas donc il pour
shabbat la grille j'ai un petit peu là
je suis épaté pas le jour
malheureusement ce n'est pas le jour dd
mercury sa rumba cdvr au curry
exactement et vert aux curistes le curry
les verts au curry week-end les petits
l'accord des trucs comme ça sur une
direction curie way son très bon score
d'ériger les verts vous êtes en train de
manger les verts en fait elle n'est pas
très très bon ticket avec dev team je te
vois pas du tout où on n'a pas néanmoins
pas du tout je suis végétarienne mais
mais je trouve que c'est hyper
intéressant que vous proposer d'autres
sources de protéines mais faut pas
oublier qu'on n'a pas besoin d'aller
jusqu'aux criquets à la sauce tomate
on peut très bien manger végétales des
pois chiches des lentilles et tout ça
est à la source de protéines mais c'est
intelligent vous êtes allez donc vous
avez cherché le truc je suis d'accord
avec vous nous l'idée c'est justement de
passes contre 1,2 d'ouvrir le champ des
possibles de richard dépression peut
manger des pois chiches et on peut aussi
manger des insectes que c'est un des
gros problème c'est que c'est pas moi
qui l'inventé la ffa ou qui l'a dit déjà
depuis des années c'est à cause de ça
qu'on s'est lancé qu'on l'associé
clément dans cette folle aventure c'est
qu'on va manquer de poids voilà ce qui
est intéressant c'est que justement ces
petits animaux ils prennent moins de
surface par exemple les vaches et d'au
moins de trucs comme ça que c'est
intéressant car il en faut beaucoup pour
je n'aurais pas forcément ce que c'est
les mêmes rapports côté que la viande
règles par exemple vendu granola ça va
aller très vite dans un mois la baisse
que vous avez juste à côté nous assez du
grenat granola cette question la fois ci
on voit pas d'insectes mais il n'est pas
en retard de l'être non non c'est un mix
de céréales pour le petit déjeuner donc
là en fait là qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
faire comme repas pour nos
téléspectateurs voilà pour être un repas
équilibré que ça ça n'a pas suffi sort
on mange on va se dire mire après on va
normal c'est une première chose pour
pour commencer on peut faire un petit
apéro avec des airs décrivent bien fait
à la maison genre avec votre famille
doux mais bien sûr avec les amis en fait
nous si vous voulez on est encore dans
un moment d'alimentation et c'est ce qui
en fait un énorme au nez on n'est pas
encore dans l'alimentation on est dans
l'expérience on est en train de faire
découvrir aux gens parce que bien
entendu ça ce sont des produits d'appel
c'est pour commencer c'est pourra
s'initier à l'entomophagie machine
arrière en effet le but c'est d'aller
sur des produits plus grande
consommation et c'est ce qu'on est en
train de faire avec notamment du granola
qui permet aussi de gommer les fringues
bruges et au pardon savez de pepito
les grandes aulas et les céréales c'est
pas la marque de gâteaux